-Luke, welcome back. How are ya?
-Good to see ya.
How is your life?
-My life is all right.
A little strange.
I assume it's a little strange
for you, as well.
I imagine a new album,
the way you would expect
to be promoting it is on the
road in front of adoring fans,
and yet, here you are
Zooming with me.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, that's as enjoyable.
I mean, but we -- Yeah, I mean
we originally had the albu
scheduled to come out in April
and we had all these tour --
this big tour that was gonna
set up the album, but obviously,
as you know,
a lot of stuff has changed
But, hey, you got to --
When, you know --
You got to do what you --
You got to play the hand
that's dealt.
But we're excited
to have the album out.
I've had a lot of these song
completed for some time now.
So I'm tired of riding aroun
listening to 'em in my truck
I'm ready for the fans
to hear 'em.
-Well, one of the things you had
to make do with the situation,
the hand we're dealt, you ha
dealt yourself acres and acres
of farmland, and you actuall
planted sweet corn.
Is this the first time you'v
planted corn there?
-I have had small little patches
of sweet corn,
but when I got --
When we started quarantine
I had my nephew,
two of his buddies that were
going to college with him,
and then two other boys
that we were quarantined with.
And I totally -- I was like th
old dad that runs in on 'e
like, "All right, boys. You're
not laying around all day.
Let's start a garden."
So, I told 'em, you know, I go
on the phone and I started
ordering all of these tomato
seeds, cantaloupe, watermelon,
sweet corn, and we just --
I went and bought us a tractor
We started tearing up
all this -- You know,
I've got some land around my
house.
We were out there working.
The boys built this unbelievable
greenhouse,
so we grow all this stuff,
we plant the corn.
The corn is like the prettiest
patch of corn I've ever seen
And then all of these boys g
back to college
and they leave -- essentially,
they abandoned me.
They used me, they used me
and, yeah.
My -- You know, I left the far
to chase music,
and then I go back to the farm
and now, yeah,
I need to stick with music
I can grow stuff.
Now, marketing the corn
and selling the corn
is a whole different deal.
-This is very like you
to involve your family
in your endeavors.
Your music video
for "One Margarita"
had the whole gang.
We have a photo of your mom.
Whose idea was that?
-Well, the funny thing is so
we filmed the video in Mexic
at Crash My Playa
back in January.
You know, my mom calls me
that morning.
You know, she is like,
"Oh, I'm under the weather
I'm tired. I don't want to com
down here and do the video
I'm tired." So she shows up,
and when the lights, camera,
action -- when the cameras roll,
you know, she's dancing on
barstools, table tops.
You know, getting on
people's shoulders.
I mean, so she knows how
to turn on the charm.
-Hey, I want to ask about this
as well, because the song
"One Margarita,"
it's a little bit misleading
because it's about
three margaritas and a shot.
When you write a number-one song
like that,
that has a drink order in it
and you are recognizable
and you have fans,
the kind of fans that you have
I imagine that this is --
and I have heard that
this is a drink order
that will be sent over to your
table?
-Yeah. So, here where we're from
in South Nashville, you know
the restaurants are open
at half-capacity.
So, you know, my wife and I,
we'll roll out and sit
at a little table,
and then someone will send u
three margaritas and a shot.
And they're like --
and then I'm like,
"Well, guys, I appreciate
the sentiment and the gesture,
but, you know, I mean,
I don't --
I don't really need to
black out here."
-Right.
-At me and my wife's
go-to restaurant.
They are like -- and then two --
like -- it's like becoming
the thing where, yeah, I mean,
people expect me to just dow
three margaritas and take a shot
of tequila, and just, you know
hop in the car and start,
you know, ramming cars as
I fly out of the parking lot
So I've got -- you need to hel
me develop a letdown line.
-Yeah.
-We got to --
-I think a letdown line is
better,
because my other idea was --
it just doesn't seem
very country to record
a song called like
"Half a Glass of Pinot."
-[ Laughs ]
-Right? You can't do that.
-Half a glass of pinot.
Full glass of pinot.
One and a half glass of pinot.
Syrah, syrah.
-There you go.
You are getting there.
Hey, last thing.
This has been recirculating.
This happened a while ago,
right, because people
throw things on stage,
and here is video of you
getting hit with a beer can.
Obviously,
not the most ideal place.
When you saw it, did you
remember when that happened?
-Well, I remember it
happening, and then I saw it
Somehow it got shared of m
taking the beer can to
the privates, to the junk.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, you know, it's like fans
are, you know -- fans get caught
up in the moment, you know
But, yeah, I mean, throwin
a beer can right at my crotc
is --
And you can see my reaction.
It's --
I held it together, though
-That's what I was going to say.
You had to walk a narrow line,
and I was very impressed.
And, hey, very excited
you are going to stick aroun
and do a song for us.
Thanks so much.
It's always so great
to see you, Luke.
-Hey, thanks for having me
Thank you.